good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I'm
wearing a suit which must mean it's time
to talk about money so since 2014 all
the ad revenue from this YouTube channel
has been evenly split between our
charity the foundation to decrease
worldsuck
and a fund that sponsors online
educational content and through that
fund we've been able to give grants to
dozens of projects over the years I'll
link to a few of the recent ones below
but I mention this because submissions
are now open for the next round of
grants so if you know of a great edu
creator who needs a few thousand dollars
to become an even greater
edu creator or if you are such a person
there is a link to apply in the
doobly-doo below quick pause to note
that Hank and I don't do this because
we're like oh so noble or whatever we do
it because we can afford to we have
other jobs that pay well like for
instance did you know that my new book
Turtles all the way down is available in
bookstores everywhere and the New York
Times just named it one of their
favorite books of the year back to
charity right so the other half of
vlogbrothers revenue goes to the
foundation to decrease worldsuck which
despite its silly name is a real charity
it is federally sanctioned your
donations are tax-deductible all that
stuff and despite the so-called ad
pocalypse on YouTube and broader
challenges faced by the advertising
funded parts of the Internet
vlogbrothers has had a really good year
the foundation has about 125,000 dollars
in the bank right now 15,000 more than
we did at this time last year largely
thanks to the money we made helping
distribute the excellent documentary
caddy but soon we will have nothing in
the bank because it will all be given
away after the 11th annual project for
awesome a 48-hour live streamed charity
extravaganza that begins at noon Eastern
Time on December 15th during the first
half of the project for awesome we raise
money for pre selected charities this
year they are Save the Children which
we've worked with extensively over the
last decade and also last mile health an
amazing nonprofit that trains and paves
community health workers in Liberia and
during that part of the p4a every dollar
you donate will count as much more than
$1 because Hank and I will match every
donation up to $250,000 and donors to
both charities will also match your
donations so your money will go a long
way and then during the second half of
the project for awesome we raise money
for charities chosen by nerdfighteria
and this is where you can help raise
money and awareness for your favorite
charities make a video about a charity
you think should receive a grant
uploaded at noon Eastern Time on
December 15th and then people can vote
for your charity at
projectforawesome.com now you might be
thinking I don't have many subscribers
no point in me making a video but every
your charities get grants thanks to
brilliant videos made by creators with a
few dozen or even zero subscribers
making a p4a video is also an excellent
way to support a charity even if you
can't afford to donate to it as for how
to make a good p4a video I highly
recommend Hanks guide which you can find
in the doobly-doo below in the past
grants have gone to organizations from
The Trevor Project to the against
malaria foundation it's all up to you
your videos and your votes over the past
5 years the project for awesome has
raised more than 5.8 million dollars for
charities and we're hoping to make this
the best year yet no pressure or
anything a little bit of pressure it
occurs to me that no pressure or
anything em - a little bit of pressure
it's kind of my approach to everything
okay four last things one I will be in
comments to answer any questions you
have to let us know who you'd like to
see us project for awesome co-hosts let
us know if you have any perk ideas that
would tempt your dollars toward charity
and lastly if by some chance you want to
donate a lot of money to the project for
awesome likes a $1000 or more and you
want to join the matching donation fund
email me with the subject line matching
at Hank and John at gmail.com Thank You
Hank dftba I'm going to take off this
suit I will see you on Friday